四十種類の瞑想法を教えているところですけど
このアヌッサティというところだと思います
そちら アナパアヌッサティは説明してないでしょうね
まあとにかくこのアヌッサティというところ
あの頁の八番目見てください
アヌッサティと言ったっても
これはサティではありません
それはまあ 何か考え方
何か概念 何か言葉 何かを心で持って
それはずっと繰り返して念じることなんですね
ですから ヴィパッサナーサティの瞑想とは関係ないんです
その区別をはっきりさせてほしいんですね
で あの だいたいパーリ語に詳しくないんですから
ただ言葉で あ 同じことやとね
私は種類のサティ知ってるんだとかなんとか言う可能性もあります
サティは種類しかないし
ですから これは あの ごく普通に世の中にある瞑想法と全く似ている同じものなんですね
何か言葉 何か概念 何か考え方
心でずっと念じている
そこで あの これは仏教の瞑想法だから
仏教では何でもいいということは言わないんだから
人間にはこの選んでるんですね
こういうこういうことをやったらどうでしょうか
ですから 世の中には数えられないほど念じる瞑想はあります
呪文を念じることも一つ
その随念の瞑想なんですけど
でも仏教ではそこら辺はまあ置いといて
いくらかは選んでいるんですね
それはなぜ選んだかというと
まあ仏教の場合は この人間に何か超能力
神秘体験 何かそういう変なものをついてほしいという気持ちは全くないんですね
で それと人がね ちょっと違う服を着て
どうだい 私の服はすごいでしょうというような感じなんです
例えば自分がオーダーメイドですごいお金払って
特別に服を作ってもらって
あの 着ていると それはどうせ世の中でそれ一しかないんだからね
まあ特別に見えるかもしれませんだけどね
で そういうふうな遊び方というか
楽しみ方っていうのは
まああまり人間の成長にはつながりません
どうですかと 私の今首にかけているこのアクセサリーは特別に注文して作ってもらったんだと
で なぜこれこういうふうに言うことは成長につながりませんかというと
そこでこの我々の心の中で基本的にある自分と他人と区別している
それから自分が他の人より何か特別なものがなければ気が済まないという
あの高慢の働きなんですね
ですから 高慢の働きが働く限り
人間には智慧がないんです
智慧が現れてくるということは
どんどんどんどんこの区別感
分別感という言葉おかしいんですけど
差別感という言葉でいいんですね
この差別感は心からどんどん消えていくはずなんですね
たとえ皆様方 ヴィパッサナー瞑想をなさっているかもしれませんだけど
それでもすごく差別感
心の中にあるならば この怒り
嫉妬 憎しみ そういうのははっきりして差別感なんですね
他人と自分を区別して否定して
いこうという気持ちなんですね
だから いくら相手に気に入らない性格があろうとも
何があろうとも なんとか接点ないんですか
なんとか仲良くする方法ないんですかと探すことは慈悲の働きで
あの人うるさくたってもいいんじゃないですかと
でも他のいいところはありますよと
いくらうるさくてみんなに文句ばっかり言うんだけど
もし何か頼んだらちゃんとやってくれるんだと
そういうふうに何かいいとこありまして
そういう接点ね 自分と他人との平和的に生きていられるために接点を探すような我々の心変えるならば
変えているならば 自動的に自然に変えているならば
それはヴィパッサナー瞑想の結果
自分で苦労して修行して差別感を心で育てないんだと頑張ると
それは戒律のレベルなんですね
戒律というシーラの段階なんですね
ヴィパッサナー瞑想ではそんなにシーラ守ることは大変難しい
ストレス溜まるんです
シーラっていうのはやりたいことはやらないことなんですね
本当は心がやりたいんです
それは悪いことだから
わざと自分の気持ちを抑えてやらないようにする
それは修行のシーラの段階
シーラの段階なんです
シーラといえば日本の発音ですけど
シーラの段階なんですね
もしサティでもってヴィパッサナーを持ってどんどん区別差別感消えちゃって
まあそれほど派手に活動しないというならば
いわゆる特別に苦労しなくても
心の中から機能しなくなってるならば
それは瞑想の結果で何もストレスないんです
人の普通だったら気に入らないところや性格や見えても
まあそういうことはあるんだけど
人間っていうのは誰でも不完全だからね
誰にでも何かあるんだと
文句言いたければ文句言えるところは
でもまたいいところもあるんだから
そこら辺で私たちはその欠点を持って仲良くしましょうと
そういう風に 平和 調和的に心が育っていくならば
それはヴィパッサナー瞑想の結果なんですね
それでこの前に戻りますけど
高慢に求めてどうだい
私はこれすごいでしょうとかね
私にこういうことできるんだからすごいでしょうという気持ちで行動すると
高慢が働いていて そこに自分と他人を区別していて
差別していて 自分が他人と競争しているんですね
他のその他大勢の人々と競争してるんです
だから競争するということは戦いであって
苦しみの元なんですね
たとえどんな形の競争であろうか
結果としては自分が精神的にストレス溜まって苦しむんですね
競争しているんだから
必ず相手が自分に対しても競争するんですね
もし人がそうやって 前の例に戻りますけどね
オーダーメイドで大変高い
何十万円もかかる服を着て
どうですか この服は すごいでしょうと言ったところで
その話聞いた人にはそんなにお金がないかもしれません
その人は違うところで頭を使って
自分の能力を使って 1,000円の服を買って
それはほんのちょっとのことで
100円の何か他の生地やら何か買って
何かの花をつけたり いろんなことをしたりして
また 1,000円で売ってるアクセサリーとつなげて
もっと綺麗に見えるようにするかもしれませんね
それでその方はどうですか？これ全部まとめたっても 2,500円もかかってないんだと
でもこれしか世の中でこの人しかいないんだと
そういうことですから
この競争の場合はやっぱり自分を攻撃されるんです
ですね ですから悔しくなるんですね
もしその二人がなんだこんな安いもんばっかし買ったってもというふうに自分一人で思うかもしれませんだけど
世の中の人々は もし安いものを着ている人の方が美学的な感覚が完成しているんだと認めちゃったらどうしますか
ものすごい悔しくなっちゃうんですね
ですから 競争は一切苦しみの元だというのはお釈迦様の教えなんですね
ですから 瞑想でもってでも
他人と自分を分別するための何か特別な
ちょっとした能力とかね
こういう神秘体験とか超能力とかあったら
それもやがて足かせになっちゃうんですね
悪いとは言ってないんです
人は成長するのはいつでもいいことで
でもそれを何か特別能力を身にすることを目的にしたら
あまり時間経たないうちに大変な足かせになって堕落してしまっちゃうんですね
そういうストーリーっていうのは
注釈書でも瞑想説明してるところでもいつでも言うんです
瞑想しなさい サマーディしなさいとかね
いろいろ能力つきなさいと言いながら
そこはそんな大したことないんだと
世間的な能力だけですよと
で 危ないんですよと 堕落する可能性ありますよと
高慢になってはいけませんと
あるこのお釈迦様の時代のストーリーなんですけどね
あるお坊さんが瞑想して
何かそうやってこのサマーディやって
いろいろまあちょっとしたいろんな能力ついたんですね
それで彼がすっごくこれでもう喜んで喜んで大長老たちが人話してるんですね
まあ普通の仏教の話 お釈迦様の人の弟子の中に入るもう大阿羅漢たち人でしたけども
話していると この人は口を挟むんですね
口を挟むんだけど この長老たちが聞かない
そこで長老たち一番偉い長老がもう叱ったんですね
黙っていなさいと 長老たちが喋っていたのはごく一般的な仏教の内容なんです
彼がすごい瞑想のことはあだこだとかね
言いたくて言いたくて
黙っていなさい 長老たちが話す場合は黙ってる
黙っているんではないかと
それで間もないうちにその人を減速しちゃったんですね
そこでその話を聞いて
その大長老にあなたはもう知っていたんですか？あ
これはまあ知っていたんだけど
これはもうあまり長持ちしませんと
だからその大長老たちにもそういう能力があったんです
彼の心はもうまるっきり読めていたんですね
今 禅定があって欲がなくても
まあ二 三週間でもう全部堕落して
もう減速までしちゃう
それぐらい煩悩のこと
煩悩が働いているということは
まあ繊細的に働いているということはもう全く見えていましたし
綺麗に 今本人にそれを言ったっても意味がない
理解しませんし 一旦ああやってプライドを壊した方が後で役に立つんですね
彼が堕落して またサイキに戻って
また自分のお坊さんに散々いじめられて
また嫌な気持ちになって
また戻ってきたんだからね
やっぱり偉いお坊様方の話を聞いた方が良かったんではないかということで戻ってきましたけども
そういうふうなストーリーっていうのは
一応いくらかはあります
サマーディだけでは堕落したケースというのは
それでこちらでなぜどういうふうにサマーディ瞑想を推薦しているかというと
やっぱりこのサマーディ瞑想してサマーディが生まれても
この心の煩悩をなくすことを高慢なくすことを目的にしているんですね
智慧が現れてくることを目的にしているんですね
ですから 例えば何かの呪文オームとかね
何かを唱えたっても 統一状態が生まれる可能性はありますけど
それでもって智慧は生まれてこないんですね
迷信は生まれてくるかもしれません
やっぱり宇宙の創造をした一番最初のエネルギーはオームですよ
で 言葉のアとイとウだから人間発する全ての人類発音すること
音の基本 それなんですね
アとイとウなんですね
それはこのオになるんで
サンスクリット語ではこの数字を数字じゃなくて
この母音を縮んじゃうという
まとめてまとめるという法則がありまして
アは一応抜けますけど
イとウと集めたら あるいはアとウと集めたらオになるという決まりがあります
それでオという字は 何と言いますか
何名詞ですか ニュートラルジェンダー
何と言いますか 中性名詞ですから
そこでんというものを入れちゃうんですね
それでオームという言葉ができてるんです
意味がないんです でもそちらでは意味を持ってるんです
三つですから アとイとウだからね
だからヒンドゥー教自体にも
やっぱり創造する神がいて
世界を管理する神がいて
世界を破壊する神がいてという三神論なんですね
ですから 数学的に人間の数学やらいろんな立場から考えちゃうと
しっかりぴったしではないかと思うかもしれませんだけど
結局そういう瞑想して
もしサマーディみたいな経験があったら
やっぱりこの音自体が
大変なパワーですよとか何とかとか思う可能性はありますね
でもヴィパッサナーでは何言うかというと
音っていうのはただの音
すぐ消えるもんだと 無常にならない音はありませんと
音自体は無常でなきゃ成り立たないんですね
そういうことだから 具体的に論理的に知識智慧の方が発達しちゃうんですね
仏教的な見方だったら
迷信は全部壊れて壊れていっちゃうんですね
人間が好きですよっていうことは
仏教では気にしないんです
やっぱり人間はそういう感覚的なものやら
それから感情的なものやら
すごく好きなんですけどね
でもそれ自体は無知の道だと
いくら一般的に公で好きであろうともダメですよというのは仏教の道ですね
そういうことでこういう瞑想を選んでいるんですね
その中でこの今日はこのアヌッセティはまた
説明する必要はないんですけど
ブッダアヌッセティっていうのはブッダのことを念じる
あるいはブッダにはつの特色がありますね
で そういうつの特色から一つの言葉を選んでずっと念じることもよろしいし
もう一つ この 念じるといったっても考えることもいいんです
ブッダにすべて肯定的に考えなくちゃいけないんですね
どういう人物でしたかと
どういう能力ありましたかとかね
そうやって なぜブッダに阿羅漢と言うんですか？なぜサンマサンブッダと言うんですか
そうやって論理的にもう
学問的にすごくこの考えたっていうのも
それも一つの瞑想なんですね
ダンマについても同じことで
お釈迦様おっしゃった真理そのもの
あの苦って何ですかと
あの受胎って何ですかと
渇愛って何ですかと ああいうふうに苦しみで考えたっていうのも
それも法随念になります
あるいは法の六徳ありますから
その一つ二つ 一つぐらい選んでずっと念じるということの瞑想になります
で サンガーヌッスティっていうのは
まあ阿羅漢たちやらこの悟った人々のことですから
これ十徳書いてますのでね
スッティパンノ・バゴート・サーガサンゴット
そういう人でも選んで
なぜスッティパンノと言うんですか
なぜウジュパティパンノと言うんですか
とくとん観察する それは瞑想なんですね
考えてみる 探してみる
調べてみる 理解してみる
あるいはそんなことをしないで
ただ単に唱えると どっちでも瞑想なんですね
まあシーラーヌッスティっていうのは自分の道徳的な生き方なんですね
自分がどんな道徳的な生き方をしているんですかと
他の人々は普段普通にやってることなんですけど
自分もまあ正直に聞けばやりたいことなんですけど
自分がそれをやらないで自分の心をコントロールしているんだと
だから自己管理できてるんだと
そうやってポジティブ的に
例えば自分がまあ 10年間も一つも嘘ついたことはないんですよとかね
ああいう風にそこを観察してみる
嘘をつかなくちゃいけないいろんな場面に出会った時も
自分がどのようにそのことを問題を乗り越えたかと
嘘をつかないで乗り越えたかとかね
それ観察すると 自分が本当に自己管理できる立派な人だよということは
まあ肯定的に自分が明るくなってくるし
すごく自信がつくんですね
確信がつくんですね まあ何か自分だったらやろうと思えばやれるんだと
終わりまで すごい すぐ三日坊主でやめる人ではなくて
まあ根性強くてちゃんとやれる人ですよというふうにポジティブ的な人間になるんですね
シーラーヌッスティから
まあチャーガーヌッスティっていうのは
言葉通りにこの施しのこと
人を助けること で そういうことについていろいろ考えたり見たりする
あるいは自分で今まで行ってきた他人を
他の生命を助けるためにやってきたものをいろいろ考えてみたりすると
そういうことによって自分の欲がどんどん低くなっちゃうんですね
ブッダーヌッスティからはこの信
確信 仏教で言ってるサッダ―
信仰かな まあサッダ―っていうのはお釈迦様に対する納得いくことなんですね
まあ人類の生命の中で最高たる生命はお釈迦様でしたと
私はその人の弟子であって
そのお釈迦様がおっしゃっていることは実践している人やという
お釈迦様に対するすごい信頼
確信 納得というものが成立する
で ダンマーヌッスティの場合も同じくなんですけど
もうちょっと違う専門用語も使ってるんで
その場合もやっぱりまあ言えばサッダ―なんですけどね
また違う言葉も専門用語もありますけど
アビダンマでは入ってないんです
で だから日本語で何言うかわかりませんだけど
この真理に対する納得なんですね
教えに対する納得 時々人々いるんですね
あまりある個人を個人の不安になるよりは
真理に真理を好む で 私たちも世の中を見ると
時々すごいことを言う人々いるんですね
言ってることはすごいしっかりしていることなんですけど
人はあまりまああまり賛成できないとね
その場合はその人の個人的な性格ではなくて
その人の能力と知識は素晴らしいと認める方法もありますね
時々人の人格そのものが大変素晴らしくて
それに惹かれる場合もありますね
その差なんですね ブッダーヌッスティ
ダンマーヌッスティっていうのは
で サンガーヌッスティの場合は
一般的な心理的な働きっていうのは
このサンガっていうのはグループですから
例えば社会でその時その時みんな考えたりするものにはみんな賛成するでしょうね
例えば興味なくても みんなそういうことを考えたり
何か社会問題とかなんとか考えたりすると
みんなそこに惹かれてそのものについて考えたりするでしょうし
例えば国籍不明の船が二隻が日本に入ってうまく逃げたんだと
そこは国民が日本の方々はどのように取っているか分かりませんだけど
もしそれは社会問題になったならば
みんなそれについて考えちゃうんですね
日本の国の安全性はどうしますかとかね
日本の自衛隊はもう何で間抜けないんですかとかね
世界で それは私個人の考え方なんですけど
もう世界ですごい力強い
ものすごい技術はね アメリカさえほしがるほどの軍事的な技術を持ってるんだけど
まあうまく逃げる それで日本の日本を守るんだと言って
アメリカ兵隊さんだやらいっぱいいるんだけどね
もうちょっと下手こと捕まるのにね
全然助けに来ないとかね
だから何のためにいるんですかとかね
やっぱり捕まった方が問題がはっきりするでしょうにね
で 韓国みたいにね いっぺん撃って殺すっていうことは
やっぱり日本のはね まあちょっと無理でしょうし
ですから捕まるしか方法ないでしょうしね
まあそれは置いておいて
もしそういう問題でも
もし日本の社会のみんな考えるように
みんなではなくて たくさんの人々考えるようになったら
誰でもそれについて考えたりする
そういう我々の人間としての我々の生き方があるんですね
ある個人に惹かれる ある人の言っている真理に惹かれる
そうやってそうでないと
一般的にその時みんなに興味ある何かの問題に惹かれるとかね
その心のその三種類の働きを見て
ブッダのダンマのサンガのそれという
この随念瞑想できてるんです
うまくできてるもんなんですよ
単なる人々を強引に仏法僧について
あの 何て言いますか マインドコントロールしようとしてるものじゃないんです
ですから 例えば私はどんな瞑想いいんですかというと
自分の性格からわかるでしょうに
自分が個人に惹かれるか
個人の教えに惹かれるかどうか
あるいはみんなやってることだったら自分もやる性格ですかと自分で知ってるでしょうに
それだったら そのブッダダンマサンガの一つ
その自分に合ってるものを選べばいいんです
超簡単です シーラメスニの場合はシーラがなければいい
自分が全く道徳何もないだらしない人間だったら
それはもうかえって悪いんですね
その瞑想は ものすごくこの
何て言いますか 落ち込んでしまっちゃいますからね
薄になってしまっちゃいますから
やらん方がいいし まあチャーカーヌスティの場合もやっぱり
[笑い]そこでサンガーヌッスティ瞑想するとどうなるかというと
やっぱりこの あの この悟ることの可能性と悟られるということと
それから人間として生まれたならば
何か生命 生命としての目的に達成しなくちゃいけないんだと
ただ金儲けることやら
もう普通日常生活のことだけに人生をね
無駄に使うんじゃないんだと
生まれてきたならば生まれたという
それ何かその目的に達成しなくちゃいけないんだというふうな
この一般的にこのもう心をしっかりするんですね
で もうこれできるんだと
大勢の人々はそれ体験しましたから
自分にもできるんだという確信が生まれてくる
もう一つ このサンガといえば
この完全に清らかな組織ですね
完璧です 個人個人で見ていないんだから
個人個人では完璧じゃないんです
ですから この その組織のことを観察すると
自分もやっぱり道徳正しい立派な人間にならなくちゃいけないというふうに気持ちが変わってきますね
チャーガーヌッスティの場合は欲がなくなってしまうし
それでデーヴァタヌッスティありますね
神々のことを念ずると
で それできるのはこの神々いるんだと
自分の文化 自分の生きている社会
あるいはまあ一般的に信じる人々なんですね
まるっきりいないと思っていると
それは意味がないんですね
ですからまあ まあ仏教で生まれて
仏教の中で生まれて育てる人々にとっては
この生命の多次元性っていうのはね
まあごく一般的な日常茶飯事の知識だから
もう神々やらね 人間より違う次元の生命っていうのはいるんだっていうことはみんな
信じてはいますね そのまま別に証拠あるないと考えずに
そこでこの神々を念ずる場合は
どれ誰かの神の名前を念じるんじゃない
そこら辺ではっきりと瞑想の仕方が決まってるんです
ヴィシュヌ神やらシヴァ神やら弁財天やら
もうなんとか大将天やら鬼子母神やら色々ありますけど
そうやって誰かを念じるんじゃないんですね
神々の存在を念じるんですね
この世の中でこの清浄浄土論で
これはそれははっきり書いてあって
神々という生命体もいるんだと
我々の目に見えませんだけど
彼らにはかなり知識能力あって
全て見えているんだと
そこら辺いっぱいいるんだと
だから私たちは表でやっていることも
裏でやっていることも
何のこともなく そちらにはバレているんだと
見られているんだと 知られているんだと
というふうに念じるんです
私は誰にも見つからないように隠れて悪いことをしたっても
神様にはもう全くもうそこら辺にいるんだから
どこに隠れたってもそこら辺もいるんだから
もう隠れるとこはないんだということで
そんな感じで念じるんですね
そこでどうなるかというと
自分には全然悪いことができなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから 弱い性格的に弱い人々
すぐ何て言いますか 乗せられるタイプの人々
はもう性格的に弱いんですね
ですから そういう人々は
まあそういう瞑想でもやっちゃう
なさると 実践してみると
心が悪いことをしないでいい心になってしまうんですね
清らかな心に変わってしまうんです
ウパサマーヌッスティっていうのは一番難しい瞑想かもしれませんだけど
それはこの間すごく説明いたしましたね
長く長く で この涅槃のことを念じることなんですね
お釈迦様おっしゃっている涅槃って何ですかと
解脱って何ですか そこで涅槃解脱っていうのは我々にはわかりませんので
それだけは体験しなきゃ絶対わからない
説明してもわからないものなんですね
ですから 逆に涅槃でないものから推測するしかないんですね
ですから 怒りで悩んでいる自分をよく味わってみて
この怒りで今自分がすごく苦しんでいるんだと
怒り全く消えたらいかに楽しいかと
安らぎがあるんだと 欲で悩んだところで
ひどい目に遭ったところでは
これは欲のせいで自分が今苦しみを味わっているんだと
この欲が消えちゃったらこんな苦しみはないだろうと
そうやって一つ一つ自分
この貪瞋痴がない状態
ものにとらわれない状態
時々人々は大変悲しみ味わうでしょうに
いろんなものにとらわれていると
人々は自殺までするでしょうに
ですから そういうもの
人の例でも見て 自分の例でも見て
やっぱりそういうふうなとらわれがない状態
いかに楽で自由でしょうかと
心は平安で安定しているんではないかと
そういうふうな感じで
涅槃という状態が素晴らしいものだということを考えたり
念じたりする だからどこかで座って瞑想しなくてもいいんです
誰かが喧嘩しているのを見たら
やっぱりこの二人が今怒りで燃えているんだと
だからこの喧嘩する二人とも今苦しんでいるんだと
自分の人生無駄にしているんだと
1時間喧嘩したっていうことは
1時間苦しんだということでしょうに
本当は瞬時に喧嘩しないで怒りを捨てることできるんですね
まあいいやと そんなことは
それ思うぐらいだけで
もう怒りは消えるはずなんですね
でもそれはできなくて
そんないいというわけにはいきませんと
思ったところで もうものすごい苦しみが暴れてくるでしょ
ですから 人が喧嘩しているのを見ても
やっぱりこういう人々は怒りで燃えて今苦しんでいるんだ
怒りがなければいかに平和で楽しいでしょうかと
幸せでしょうかというふうに
その時その時を観察すればいいんです
動物にしてもそれ見えるはずでしょうし
猫たちでもこの野良猫たちはね
もう繁殖の時期になったら
まあ鳴いて鳴いて鳴いて鳴いて
本当にすごく悲しくなるんですね
やっぱり猫 別に何か悪いことしてるわけじゃないし
もう体はね いろいろ性ホルモン出しちゃうと猫がすごく苦しみ感じちゃうんですね
どうしようもないんですね
まあ相手が見つかったらそれでまあなんとかなるかもしれませんけど
それでもやっぱりすごい喧嘩しなくちゃいけないし
だから相手が見つからない猫たちも
やっぱりずっと 1日2日
3日  4日 もう鳴くっぱなしで
だからそこを見ても まあ嫌ですよ
うるさいですよじゃなくて
それは怒りですけどね
その猫の苦しみ 欲求 から生まれてくる苦しみを見て
やっぱり欲っていうのはない方が落ち着いてるでしょ
その猫でもその気持ちがない時は何のことなく
もう何かどこかからね
ゴミ箱からでも何か拾って食べてグーグーと寝ているでしょうに
平和で ですから そういう風にこのウペクサーマ・アヌスティティというのは
いろんな角度でやりやすい瞑想なんですね
ですから 仏教の人々っていうのは
その点で大変普通の人々よりはものすごく頭がいいんです
なぜならば こういうブッダ・アヌスティティからある全てのアヌスティティは
適当に適当に その場でその場でやってますから
いつでも誰よりも頭の回転レベルですか
次元が違うんです 物に囚われてないんです
そういうわけで こういうアヌスティティ瞑想はこのサマーディ作るよりは
ものすごい立派な人間の人格を作るんですね
すごく頭のいい人々にしちゃうんですね
ものすごくこの観察能力ある
また 何かに入り込んで観察するんじゃなくて
客観的にものを見える人間になるんです
で マラナ・アヌスティティも同じことで
マラナっていうのは死ぬことで
自分が死んでないんだから
その場合も他人の死を観察するんですね
どこを見ても死というものは見えてきますからね
見えて見えますからね
経験できますからね やっぱり人は何をやって生きてきても
結果はこれだけですよ
死で終わるでしょう 私もまあ威張ったりするんじゃないんだと
何やったっても たとえ総理大臣になったっても
まあ全部死ぬまでですよと
死んだら全部もう終わっちゃうんだ
何もことなく というふうに観察するとどうなるかというと
この 世の中に対するこの執着
すごく少なくなるんですね
戦い気持ちは全く消えてしまう
威張る気持ちも消えてしまう
すっごく落ち着くんです
ものすごい落ち着くんです
それだけじゃなくて 他の人々よりものすごい立派な人間になるんです
他の人々はなんか子供のように見えちゃうんですね
おもちゃに喧嘩している子供のように
それすごい智慧の高い次元なんです
ウペクサーマ・アヌスティティも同じことでね
それも同じこと 次の瞑想はカエガタ・サティという
体を分析してみる瞑想ですね
それも人間っていうのは自分
人間はありがたいもんやと
ありがたい生命だとと言って
ものすごい高慢と差別感作ってるでしょうに
この進化の過程で この地球上で生まれたすごい生命は人間ですよ
そんな考え方は科学世界ではね
まあ進化論喋ってる人々の中でも
生物学やってる人々でも
よくよく言ってますけど
あれは良くない考え方
それでもって もう結局競争と相手を殺すことと自分威張ることと
そういうことしか出てこないんですね
だからまあ科学的にも科学ってですかね
わかりませんだけど まあ生命の誕生から今までの変化とかなんとかとかね
ほとんどスリスグなんですけど
スリスグ出て それで一番優れている生命種としてホモ・サピエンスという種類が出てきたんだとか言ってるでしょうに
だから考え方はそういう考え方だから
差別的な考え方だから
そういう風にホモ・サピエンスだけは知識的にものすごく優れている
最高な傑作だよと言ってる人々の間では人間差別はあるでしょうに
じゃあそんな話をする人々は
すべての生命は同じ仲間だと思っていますかね
もし進化論の考え方が正しいければ
それは信じる人々がやっぱり生命はみんな兄弟だと思って
兄弟意識でお互いにいたわり合って助け合って生活してるんですかね
進化論信じながら殺すでしょうに
ですから全然役に立ってないんですね
人間の幸せのためにも
こと全く役に立ってないんです
そんなもんで 心の安らぎ
人間の平和 人間の幸せ
幸福のために何も貢献してないんです
ですから ここでお釈迦様が推薦するのは
ちょっとこれを置いておいて
それを全く科学的